after you and I and Joe and Eddie went
bad on the whole situation and we were
we were calm pontificating and recog are
said yeah I was six whisky wsd Oh
Brendan got smoked weed by the end of it
Brennan I looked at him and I went well
you look pale and you're sweating I
think he because I don't feel but didn't
eat I'd nicotine yeah I'd create them
yeah I had a lot of cheese I'd candy
I had a shitload of whiskey yeah and
then I drink and I smoke weed yes am I
not by then I was like kind of sing
double yeah you're in a lot of it I just
was sick to my stomach I didn't eat and
they need all that [ __ ] and drink
and smoke
you gotta get tiny how crunk were we a
great time
how about Eddie made barstool sports he
did yeah it said Eddie gives one of the
most you know great performances on
fight companion oh hey by the way the
cops name is David usek and he took his
time out of he paid for and everything
to Vince I'm due to give this guy sign
up so shout out to yeah Miami cop David
music thanks man
you're a good man should we play this is
cool well yeah I see that
okay wait Eric Anders by the way I'm not
sure what this is
oh there's team lockdown team freedom
there's only two teams play what I'm
saying is um if I would have told you
that a year ago I said there's gonna be
I always said there's gonna be a great
if this impeachment if this impeachment
fails they're gonna come hard with that
look let's hope let me stop you because
it's not your gone let's just him go
hard my conspiratorial
what if I don't know these are just
conclusions don't make fun of me but
that's a fun time that was a great time
[ __ ] you they got video of you grabbing
your nuts me Oh
Hut kilo flagging SNA how is stuck
because my my balls I was gonna say
something while I'm doing it I knew I
was on camera my balls were stuck under
my [ __ ] hate that I literally had my
balls were stuck under my body I was
like [ __ ] care I knew I was on camera
I got my ball why do I look the oldest
are you in surgery
I kinda well I gotta tie my beard I
don't know you don't look right now I
look cute you look so cute thank you
love the cat I love cats all I care
about is what women like cat say yeah
you guys are fast and two women tidy
your lids done though
no my mother no the the the it gets
worse worse in my family it's hereditary
so I will you will not see my eyes in a
couple years
it'd be cool so my mom and the people on
that side of family get it done so did
your mom get it done but when I get it
done I'm gonna come back and I'm gonna
see if you noticed oh let's see there's
a screen shot that's awesome that's
funny
yeah I know there was an aerial shot but
I was like my [ __ ] [ __ ] on him I
was like let me pull these bad boys down
yeah a bunch of people set screen shots
to fighter the kid yeah nice dick
brother what's great about I spread yes
I did but what's great about that whole
situation is that I just you just don't
give a [ __ ] right it's like what I was
gonna leave and throw up right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]